you understand
all right so
we're going to now I think we might have
one more video maybe two for Gateway
Aikido video 15. okay two maybe one to
two parts so now we're going to go into
we have all everything we said in mind
and we're going to go into now doing
giwasa against the traditional strikes
okay so first let me repeat what I
shared and then we'll get to your
question because I would agree that is
the gist of the the biggest thing
aikidoka do not understand
okay so one
uh remember giwasas not sparring so
we're not sparring
um we're really looking for an energetic
reconciliation manifested through ikey
right uh a physical reconciliation
manifested through non-contestation and
of course you have to have reconciled
the two minds in order to do either one
of those so
is you put that all together we're
trying to manifest Taco okay
not sparring
but we don't want to game it okay
because you can't really do there's
there's no there's no need for a
Reconciliation of the two minds if we're
gaming it okay so in particular when he
strikes
he has to deliver his strikes
in The Sweet Spot
where I actually have to address it okay
so in other words if he gets too close
before he delivers his strike
that is what I should be doing
if he's too far away when he delivers
his strike he's never going to get me
I'm just going to keep
people so in it's in in Aikido Kion waza
in Striking it's replicating The Sweet
Spot not too far away where you can just
move out of the way
but not too close that you really got
hit as you're coming in so the UK has to
figure out for example for Safari and
I'm the UK I have to figure out where
I'm just out of his range okay this is
not out of his range he would dance as I
try to zero in on him and he would dance
every time I would zero in on him
but I can't do this either
okay let's say You dance around and I go
like this yeah I'm gonna get him
eventually
but he would throw Stripes as like here
and then you're gonna want to stop
getting him okay so you go back to kihon
was a striking they have to be thrown to
wound where you can be just out of range
and respond okay
all right
that said I was gonna be the UK there
but that said now I'm not good you don't
want to wait you're not gonna wait there
You're Gonna Keep moving before he goes
okay
don't wait there remember that point
you're not going to sit here and try to
get something going no no no
before he goes that's where you go and
then he would try to get you
because he's trying to get you
somewhere in him trying to get you
things are going to touch
then you seek a Nike adhesion at the
contact Point not fighting the strike
not fighting the arrow
fighting the Archer Okay so
on Chris's Point never no I've already
move it
just like if we were doing grabs I'm
already moving do you see as he's
grabbing so same thing here I'm already
moving that's where he came in continue
to throw the strike
we don't want the UK to strike past me
like somebody that has no concept he
goes
just like if we were sparring and he's
trying modern strikes on me whatever and
he sees me moving you're gonna see him
adjust
same thing here as I as he goes and I'm
moving he adjusts
so that's Chris's Point go when you just
when you feel he has a beat on you when
does he have a beat on that's where the
training comes in okay but I'm not gonna
wait here
don't get stuck on the Arrow this is
also a big problem for Aikido people
says I watched you guys a lot of you got
stuck on the Arrow the Arrow's not
important go ahead the air is so not
important that if I didn't have a
contact point I don't care he has to
come around and get a contact book
do you guys understand that okay so I
keep moving out of the way there's his
strike and I'm on the
Archer not the arrow okay
moving moving moving moving
[Music]
can you guys see that and then it
becomes just like your grab techniques
okay all right let's try it against
good movement but you're chasing the
arms
keep going
better
good movement
recognize his Yin movement if he goes
yet
you can enter you can strike
move move move move
you went for the arm
body better good
get focused between Reps don't disengage
like that
nope you're waiting
move move move move
move move move move move
don't see how you swat it on that arm
that's chasing the arrow
oh
chasing you chase the arrow again
good
Get Ready Get Ready stop stop
disengaging
engage engage move move move move
[Music]
stop okay so several times I had to say
stop disengaging okay so when you do
Taco misaki so for example let's say I'm
doing I'm doing the the grips and I
throw
all right so all right let's just do
that one again so I'm here and I throw
him
the way he got up I've moved into the
Zodi Sanctuary okay so one more time so
you can see it I move at you the way he
got up boom I moved this way
yeah so he for him to craft me he
already went into the front position you
see that as opposed to I'm here I go
like this
and then I let him come back into me and
then I throw him again
or I throw him that way
and I registered address and I found
this one
again as I here I go at him and
disappear
[Music]
it's no different there's his beat I
already moved
and the level of his intention I'm
already moving hold
moving
moving moving
movie
[Music]
so let's say I throw him on a stride
pull up most same thing I'm here boom
boom okay I don't break connection all
right so let's do that and then I'll get
back to the other number of Corrections
on stop fighting the arrow okay here we
go
so now we'll make the second correction
on fight the Archer not the arrow okay
so first let me point it out he's going
and see how you're you you go to touch
this thing
how could you you can see your arms are
going from your right to your left you
see that and you come over here and
you're like oh
it's different if I move it I'm covering
he touched me do you see that's
different
or he does a ski and you're like
that's different from this
my hand he touched me you see
so the first thing is you don't ever
reach for things don't ever reach for
things you're compact you see if we're
in here fighting we're compact it's not
going to change either because I'm doing
Aikido on them
I'm compact
move out of the way
you see yeah all that was those
movements so and remember the general
rule
your elbows
can't go outside your outer rim
okay
you know outer rims marked by my
shoulders you can't go out like that
look out
let's see out you're over here they're
out
in
in not out there's my shoulder in
so don't reach for things that's not
right
you're reaching for things as you're
making a big deal out of the stride as
opposed to the person
then secondarily if if you are touching
a lid
okay whatever I don't care so if I am
touching the limb there's your adhesion
you're in the body
found an arm
okay so if we can put those two points
together
I'm not going to have such a mental
attraction to the strike
it doesn't mean I don't touch a strike
but I'm not going to violate my outer
rim I'm not going to chase it I'm not
going to seek to touch it
but when it does touch me
I will adhere to it I'm not only
controlling the the part I'm touching I
Look to control the center
okay through that I.T adhesion all right
so you're gonna look for that now
[Music]
foreign
okay let's go
body and here
come up to the chin stop come up to the
chinmoor on that just the hips is like
low low because you're moving the center
directly there's no Leverage come up to
the chin
foreign
stay engaged after you throw you got to
get some adhesion dude
stay engaged
engage move see you're waiting you're
waiting it should be gone
no
no nope
you don't you're not moving until the
strike comes that's incorrect
move there you go
switch rolls
slow it back down
move
let them go if you don't have his Setter
Let It Go
get the arm underhook
better
hey
yeah
okay it's like you're okay how's your
your not too windy no okay well let's
slow it down okay
um so now for this question maybe I I
would say here is my Gateway Aikido
video for the question on video 15. that
that's a lot of cards for it there's
plenty to work on there uh I think you
could see that it is different
from the video you presented me and how
you end up doing it okay
but I would like to go into
our questions here okay uh the tie to
the series is that you have to do this
in order to do the other things that
you're seeing okay
so I am going to
from from the Decades of practice
I have sought and been able to cultivate
a releasing skill
the releasing skill will bring
I use the word association
to the egoic mind and I now exist
at the Mind level
somewhere
Transcendent of that
not that okay
so I try to get in that level as I'm
doing the the technique the drill I'm
not trying to throw him I don't care
about that I don't care if he hits me or
anything either I try to get into that
no mind or that unwind or not that ego
mind okay
um so here you go I don't know okay so
I'll move
[Music]
foreign
don't care about succeeding
care about the adhesion and the
reconciliation of the two minds
move get better footwork you keep going
on your arches and your knees knock
get your ground path get your midfoot
vector
[Music]
don't reach for them
so if you wouldn't deviate so much they
would touch you
okay you're about two feet past what is
required for deviation
okay
you did that weird foot thing again fix
your ground path
[Music]
don't chase them be patient
Let Let It Go Let It Go that's what I
was trying to show in that right wasn't
I just
okay so you just let it go feel free
if it goes away Let It Go
keep going
there it is
change partners
you're waiting you're you're closing on
the line you you move on the line to get
him to go on to attack the line but
you're gonna move off the line into the
spiraling footwork do you get it just
like I showed okay on the grip technique
you can move towards him but as you
smell his intention you're going to pick
one of those corners of the square okay
thank you
better
look for his Yin he tends to go in right
so you're going to see your knee strikes
open your Guillotine is going to open
Don't Force the nagawaza
your foot Stomps
this is jaywoza
[Music]
your koshimagas
do you see how you break Center every
time I I it's not you're you're hurting
you okay but you're gonna use the
opportunity got it okay
just let him go
[Music]
when you feel you picking the technique
it's not it it's not gioaza
the gold mine not understanding
we can't move into his into his young
space
[Music]
you're getting too close
you're gaming it
get get off the hip
[Music]
attack the base does your do you get you
work you want to work the top and bottom
of the lever
well
that's where you move inside the circle
on that kaitan Naga variation come on
let's go
you need me again
eating me there you go
but the first one you're out
you smell them going around you you
tighten the circle by entering one more
time
enter again do you see do you see that
okay
okay so I'm over here and the guys go
around me he's going around he's going
around as long as you keep this foot on
the center you're not going to get it
you're not going to get it you have to
take the other foot and enter
okay
if you're going to do it every time
so he's going to need it again
that's what I want you to do okay don't
go yet all right